This video is brought to you by Nebula.
Watch episode 2 right now by signing up With
the link the description.
Late on a spring evening, 1992, the Endeavor
Space Shuttle, on its maiden flight, stood
on its launch pad in Cape Canaveral Florida.
The crew sitting aboard ready to take on a
daring mission.
A rendezvous between two spacecraft in orbit.
A rescue mission.
Bruce Melnick was aboard that day.
The challenge we had was that this satellite
was never supposed to be touched by human
hands.
Once it got an orbit, it was supposed to be
way up in geosynchronous orbit over 22,000
miles up.
But it launched on an unmanned rocket that
failed to fire the second stage and send it
on its way.
So it was stuck in a useless 800 mile high
orbit.
Melnick and his crew mates were about to take
the ride of their life to rescue this satellite.
To grab it with their bare hands and attach
a new second stage, but before that could
happen a complicated series of events was
about to take place beneath them.
3 liquid fuel rocket engines were about to
burst into life with furious power that would
tilt the entire structure off axis,
held back by just 8 explosive bolts, fed with
turbopumps driving fuel out of the external
fuel tank slung underneath the Orbiter.
Meanwhile the two massive solid rocket boosters
lay dormant.
The two largest solid rockets ever made to
date, and when the signal that the orbiter's
engines were up to the challenge arrived,
an inferno would be lit inside them, causing
the entire column of solid rocket fuel inside
to erupt.
Lifting the revolutionary reusable space plane
off the ground and to orbit.
This is the insane engineering of the Space
Shuttle
We are mere moments away from launch.
Helium and nitrogen have purged the main engines,
the flight surfaces and main engine gimbals
have been tested.
The Shuttle is now fully fueled and under
its own power, no longer connected to the
launch pad.
Ten seconds are left.
Sparkler-like igniters fire underneath the
engine to burn any stray hydrogen as the Shuttle
prepares to open the main fuel valve.
Liquid hydrogen begins to race through the
fuel lines, pushed by the pressure of the
tanks, through the engines nozzles, where
it begins to expand and turn into a gas.
This gaseous hydrogen drives a low pressure
turbopump turbine, elevating the rate of flow
of hydrogen through the fuel lines.
This is all happening in the blink of an eye,
less than a second later the main oxidizer
valves open, unlocking the fuels true power.
Fuel and oxygen meet in the two high pressure
turbopumps, raising flow rates even higher.
Back in the nozzle we see our first flames.
[REF] Oxygen levels are still low, and combustion
instabilities cause the engines to rattle,
but the engine is now ready to enter its next
stage.
Entering open loop engine control, no longer
controlled by a prescripted start up sequence,
instead the engine constantly monitors pressure
readings and adjusts valves accordingly.
The engine begins to throttle up, oxygen valves
continually opening wider, the flame transitions
from a lower pressure orange flame to an eerie
hot blue.
The Space Shuttle is unique in that these
engines are not directly under the fuel tanks.
The expensive rocket engines were attached
to the reusable shuttle, not the expendable
external tank.
And because the main engines are offset from
the solid rocket boosters, which are holding
you to the pad, when we light off the main
engines at seven seconds, it actually bends
that stack over.
And you can feel this little lurching back
and forth.
NASA calls it twang.
kind of a real technical term.
The only thing stopping the entire shuttle
from tipping over at this point
are the hold down posts, attached to the solid
rocket boosters, which for now lay dormant,
waiting for the signal to ignite.
The pressure inside the diverging nozzle is
still lower than atmospheric pressure, and
we can see a flow separation layer, which
gradually creeps to the edge of the nozzle
as the pressure inside increases.
3 seconds until launch.
The engines are checked to ensure they are
running at 90% of their rated thrust.
The time has come for the solid rocket boosters
to ignite.
The solid rocket boosters are 45 meters long
and are filled to the brim with solid rocket
fuel, a rubbery mixture that combines both
the fuel and oxidiser into one solid material.
The oxidizer, ammonium perchlorate, makes
up nearly 70% of the mixture, while 16 percent
was the aluminium fuel
We need a way to ignite the entire column,
quickly.
The igniter itself was essentially a miniature
solid rocket motor, which itself was ignited
by an even smaller miniature solid rocket
motor.
To ensure extremely quick combustion, this
main igniter was shaped with a 40 point star
orifice.
When it comes to solid rocket motors, the
more surface area available to burn, the quicker
it will burn, rapidly producing the heat and
pressure needed to ignite the entire column
of solid propellant.
Once this happened there was no turning back
so there were several safety mechanisms in
the arming sequence to prevent it happening
accidentally.
The first part of the arming sequence began
when technicians accessed the safety and arming
device
in the top skirt of the solid rocket booster
here to remove a pin.
This pin locked a safety device in place,
preventing it from rotating into an armed
position by accident.
When it was rotated into position on command,
at t minus 5 minutes, it connected a standard
NASA detonator through a tunnel to the igniter
system.
When it fires, it begins the rapid chain of
events that brings the space shuttle to its
highest thrust, but the entire rocket is still
anchored to the launch pad, held down by the
hold down posts, 4 on each solid rocket booster.
These hold down posts anchor the solid rockets
to the ground through the aft skirt with massive
711 millimeter long and 88 millimeter wide
bolts.
The lower side of the bolt is tensioned using
a regular nut, while the upper nut is a special
kind of explosive nut, a frangible nut.
[FOOTAGE]
On two occasions (STS-2 and STS-92) two of
these frangible nuts did not fracture correctly,
something NASA described as stud hang ups.
These issues did not stop the space shuttle
from taking off, with the power of two solid
rocket boosters and 3 main engines one or
two improperly fractured nuts were not going
to stop the Space Shuttle from taking off.
These hold down posts were primarily designed
to prevent the space shuttle from tipping
over while the 3 main engines were brought
up to full throttle, or simply by a gust of
wind.
However if 4 or more stud hang ups occurred
the issue could have been mission critical,
and so a redesign was introduced for STS-126,
where a crossover assembly was included.
This new system linked the two pyrotechnic
charges in each nut to ensure they detonated
within 50 microseconds of each other.
A delay of up to 250 microseconds was possible
with the previous design and this was identified
as the main issue causing the so-called stud
hang ups.
[REF]
The shuttle is now free, with the largest
and most powerful solid rockets ever used
in human space flight powering it upwards.
Each of the solid rocket boosters provided
13,000 kilonewtons of thrust each, nearly
double that of the Falcon 9 first stage (7.6
MN)
But the very notion of using solid rocket
boosters for a crewed space shuttle was initially
met with extreme concern.
Using solid rocket boosters for human space
flight had never been attempted before.
They were nearly exclusively used for military
use, like the minuteman ICBM.
The solid fuel allowing them to stand ready,
available to launch in a moment's notice.
However, once ignited there is little that
can be done to stop them, the entire column
of propellant is ignited at once.
There are no pumps or valves that can lower
the fuel and oxidiser being delivered.
Once ignited, they stay ignited until all
of the propellant is expended.
This, ofcourse, comes with extreme control
issues that need to be engineered around.
To begin, the engine needs to be throttled
back as it expends fuel.
As fuel is used the weight of the rockets
lowers.
If the thrust isn’t lowered the rocket could
exceed its max allowable dynamic pressure
and disintegrate.
An improperly designed fuel column could make
matters even worse, as a simple circular internal
cavity will result in an increase in thrust
as the fuel is burned.
However, many different thrust profiles can
be achieved with different shapes.
A pointed star cavity will start with higher
thrust, thanks to the increased surface area,
but rapidly decrease in thrust, as the points
of the star burn down and the surface area
decreases.
This effect is increased by increasing the
number of points on the star, which is why
the igniter had 40.
Nearly every illustration online shows the
Space Shuttle Solid Rocket boosters with a
continuous cylinder
If this was the design of the fuel channel,
it could have caused issues.
The surface area of a circular internal cavity
would have increased as fuel was burned, because
the cavity's diameter and circumference would
be increasing.
This is not how the solid rocket boosters
were designed.
The upper section of the solid rocket booster
had an 11 pointed star shape.
This shape was created with this mandrel placed
inside the upper section before the fuel mixture
was poured in.
This shape then transitioned into a circular
section, however it wasn’t constant in diameter.
The diameter increased toward the nozzle.
This design provided elevated thrust at ignition,
when it was needed most, and then reduced
gradually to lower the maximum dynamic pressure
the space shuttle experienced, with the thrust
decreasing by 33% 50 seconds into flight.
When filling the solid rocket booster segments
with the propellant they were filled in pairs,
matching with its contemporary segment on
the other booster.
This allowed the two segments to be filled
using the same batch of fuel mixture, so if
there were any inconsistencies in the mix
they would be at the very least consistent
on the left and right side of the shuttle,
ensuring differential thrust from the boosters
would not drive it ofcourse.
However, all 5 of the nozzles are capable
of thrust vectoring to control the Space Shuttle
during ascent and 80% of the steering power
came from the SRBs, thanks to their power
and increased distance from the central axis
of the shuttle.
The Space Shuttles aerodynamic flight surfaces
played no part in control during ascent, but
they did actuate to reduce aerodynamic stress
and drag.
7 seconds after take off, with the Space Shuttle
traveling around 140 kilometers per hour (87
mph), a roll programme is initiated, through
asymmetric thrust vectoring of the nozzles
of the solid rocket boosters [Footage]
with actuators mounted inside the aft skirt
here.
There are 2 hydraulic actuators on each nozzle
to allow it to move in both pitch and yaw.
The space shuttle turns over 180 degrees and
pitches 12 degrees off a straight up trajectory,
placing the Shuttle on a heading towards its
assigned orbit, lowering the dynamic pressure
on the shuttle's wings, and providing the
flight crew a view of the horizon out of their
windows.
[Footage]
Ofcourse, this 180 degree rotation would not
have been needed if the Space Shuttle was
simply rotated on the launch pad, but the
launch pad was designed for the Saturn V.
The position of the service tower, and all
the supporting infrastructure associated with
it, locked the Space Shuttle into this orientation,
and it was simply easier to program a roll
than to build a new launch pad.
45 seconds into the flight something fascinating
happens.
The space shuttle exceeds the speed of sound,
and the sound of those rocket engines can
no longer reach the astronauts.
So you don't hear those rocket motors that
much anymore behind you.
But now you hear the air rushing down the
side of the shuttle in a thickest part of
the atmosphere, and it sounds like a train
howling through a tunnel when that air is
going across the rough blankets and tiles
on the outside of the shuttle.
And as the space shuttle races higher and
higher into the atmosphere and the air gets
progressively thinner, even this sound begins
to dwindle away.
for the last 1520 seconds of first stage,
it's just a quiet, very rough ride because
you're still on the solid rocket boosters
And it will get even quieter as the solid
rocket boosters reach the end of their fuel
supply 2 minutes into the flight.
Lowering chamber pressures trigger sensors
to begin the separation process, however if
these fail a backup system based simply on
time elapsed takes over.
Once triggered the thrust vectoring system
is commanded to return the nozzles to the
neutral position and the orbiter is commanded
to maintain its attitude for 4 seconds.
The SRBs are attached to the external tank
at 4 points.
Through 3 struts on the lower section of the
rocket and an additional upper connection,
each held in place by frangible connections
that are severed on command.
At the same time 8 separation motors, 4 on
top of the solid rocket booster and 4 on the
bottom, fire.
These were also solid motors and provided
over 96 thousand newtons of thrust, ensuring
the SRBs safely detached from the space shuttle
as it continued its flight to orbit.
This solid rocket booster separation process
was the thing that caught Bruce off guard
most on his first flight.
picture this, you're sitting on top of the
explosive bolts that are holding the boosters
to the tank.
So when those explosive bolts let go, it's
a large bang.
And then the booster separation motors, which
are little rocket motors that fly the boosters
away from the shuttle so it doesn't recontact
it, those exhausts are aimed right at your
windshield.
So it's staging instead of there being this
little pop and off you go in second stage,
it's this big bang, and then you're in this
fireball where the exhaust from the booster
sep motors are over the windshield, and it's
like, geez, did we just blow up?
And then very quickly you get through that
and you can see the nice dark of space ahead
of you.
So that's really the only surprise going uphill
that I had on my first flight.
At this point the SRBs are continuing to climb
in altitude, just slower than the Space Shuttle,
upon reaching their apogee, roughly a minute
later they will begin their journey back down
to earth, eventually releasing a series of
parachutes from its nose cone to slow descent
and land in the ocean to be recovered and
reused.
Meanwhile the Orbiter is continuing its journey
in its second stage of flight.
Second stage is smooth.
Matter of fact, most astronauts will call
it electric drive, but now is when the GS
start to build up and you're getting pushed
further and further back in your seat.
And then we throttle the engines back when
we reach three Gs because it is a winged vehicle.
So there's a lot of aerodynamics going on
there.
And for the structural integrity, we go ahead
and throttle back to three Gs because the
wings could come off if you accelerated a
whole lot more than that, and that would make
for a bad day.
Under the power of the 3 main engines, fed
with liquid hydrogen and liquid oxygen from
the external tank, the shuttle continues its
way to orbit.
This external tank is a bit of an anomaly,
the Space Shuttle was intended to be fully
reusable when it was first conceived, with
the fuel and oxidiser tanks incorporated into
the orbiter itself.
In fact, the Space Shuttle was envisioned
in many different forms
Ultimately funding challenges forced the Space
Shuttle’s ambitious designs to be simplified,
and the Air Force was approached to bolster
funds influencing the design to stray even
further from the original vision.
Primarily in an increased cargo bay capacity
and increased glide range.
The external tank was however the largest
compromise of design.
Gone was the idea of a manned external tank
that would glide back to land.
What would have saved money in the long run
simply would have been too expensive to develop.
Relying instead on an extendable external
tank.
A massive non-reusable structure that would
disintegrate during reentry.
The external was heavy.
It wasn’t simply two pressurized tanks,
it was a structurally integral component,
responsible for transmitting enormous loads,
it was the centerpiece of the space shuttle
system.
The structural backbone.
Connecting to both the solid rocket boosters
and the orbiter.
In order to do this the external tank had
to be strong.
It was 47 meters long and weighed 33.5 metric
tonnes, empty.
Its aluminum skin is reinforced with strengthening
rings and stringers.
This was essentially a massive thermos flask
with a spaced double skin to insulate the
cryogenic fuel inside, finally the entire
structure was covered in a layer of orange
insulation foam, which alone weighed 2.2 tonnes.
The first two space shuttle missions featured
a white external tank, coated in a fire retardant
latex, which was removed to save a quarter
tonne of weight.
The liquid oxygen tank was located on top
of the external tank.
It’s much smaller than the liquid hydrogen
tank thanks to oxygen’s much higher density,
and this is part of why the liquid oxygen
tank was placed on top of the external tank,
as it pushes the rocket's center of gravity
higher, an important aspect of stability in
flight.
If a rocket is traveling straight up drag
and lift acts through the center of pressure.
The location of the center of pressure is
determined by the location of aerodynamic
surfaces and engines, but the rocket rotates
around the center of gravity, which is determined
by the placement of mass, because of this
it makes sense to place weight higher on the
rocket, as it moves the center of gravity
above the center of pressure.
[REF]
Imagine a rocket flying with its orientation
aligned with its direction of flight, when
a gust of wind knocks it off balance it introduces
an angle of attack, which creates lift acting
through the center of pressure, and the rocket
rotates around the center of gravity.
Returning the rocket to its original position.
If the center of gravity was below the center
of pressure the opposite would happen and
the rocket would be unstable.
So, the dense liquid oxidiser was placed on
top of the external tank.
This came with the added benefit of allowing
the inter tank to be placed higher on the
external tank, as the hydrogen tank is much
larger.
The intertank is a load bearing structure
between the two tanks.
There is even a massive beam hidden within
this intertank resisting enormous compressive
loads as the solid rocket motors attempt to
push inwards.
The lower support strut holding the solid
rocket boosters takes all of the shear stress
created by the upwards thrust of the booster,
and so the upper support acts primarily in
compression.
The forward attachment point to the orbiter
is also located on the lower portion of the
intertank.
[REF]
Ofcourse, all of this liquid oxidiser and
fuel needed to get to the main shuttle engines
on the orbiter.
The liquid oxygen exits the tank here, this
pipe is massive.
46 centimeters wide.
Big enough to crawl through.
When the liquid oxygen begins to flow, it
acts much like water, and with this rate of
flow a massive whirlpool could form.
With the weight of all this fluid swirling
and sloshing inside the tank this could cause
massive instability issues, or it could even
expose the outlet and allow bubbles to enter
the engine.
So an anti-vortex and anti-sloshing baffles
are placed on the bottom of the tank where
the oxidiser exits.
Liquid oxygen travels down this pipe into
the interstage where it exits and runs along
the length outside of the liquid hydrogen
tank until it meets the primary orbiter connection
point.
This connection point connects physically
to the orbiter, but is also the primary connection
for the liquid oxygen and liquid hydrogen.
To the left and right of this truss connection
are two umbilical plates.
Which mated directly to corresponding plates
on the underside of the orbiter.
The left plate provided a connection for liquid
hydrogen and the right plate provided a connection
for liquid oxygen.
Each also had gaseous lines that brought back
gaseous hydrogen and oxygen from the main
engine to their respective tanks.
This was vital in order to maintain ullage
pressure.
Ullage is the volume of gas above a liquid
storage tank, like the cryogenic liquid oxidiser
and hydrogen tanks.
The pressure of this volume has to be maintained
as the liquid lowers.
If the pressure is allowed to lower the structural
integrity of the tanks could be compromised.
The gaseous hydrogen used to pressurize the
tank was tapped off from the hydrogen fuel
line after it went through the regenerative
cooling loops of the nozzle here, at the outlet
of the turbine exhaust manifold of the low
pressure fuel pump.
Liquid oxygen does not pass through this regenerative
cooling system and thus needed to be converted
into a gas to pressurize the tanks.
It instead was tapped off here at the outlet
of the main oxygen turbopump after passing
through a heat exchanger around the turbine
of this pump.
:
Finally there were electrical connections
on each plate too, made up of smaller electrical
wires that provided power to the external
tank and solid rocket boosters, while also
carrying vital telemetry data from each to
the orbiter's computers.
Finally there was also liquid hydrogen recirculation
connection, which was only used during the
liquid hydrogen engine chill down sequence
before launch, where the cryogenic fluid is
circulated through the feed lines, valves
and turbopumps to bring them down to temperature.
If this didn’t occur bubbles could form.
The time for main engine cutoff is quickly
approaching.
The process will be triggered by a predetermined
velocity target, around 28,000 kilometers
per hour, however it can be triggered by fuel
and oxidizer sensors detecting a low fluid
level.
There are eight propellant depletion sensors.
The four fuel depletion sensors are located
in the bottom of the liquid hydrogen tank.
However, the liquid oxygen sensors were located
downstream of the feed line, inside the orbiter.
There was also an extra 500 kilograms of liquid
hydrogen loaded over the required 6:1 oxidiser/fuel
mixture ratio.
Together these ensured that in the event the
main engine was cut off as a result of propellant
depletion, that main engine cut off occurred
in a fuel rich scenario.
As oxidizer rich engine shutdowns severely
erode and damage the reusable engines.
[REF]
The time has now come for the main engines
to shut down and for the external tank to
separate.
Frangible nuts once again explode to separate
the two structures.
[Footage]
The external tank begins to float away, leaving
the umbilical plates underneath the shuttle
exposed, and fixing that is the next challenge.
you've got to close those doors.
That's one of the first things you do.
And that's very, very critical because if
you don't close those doors, you can't reenter
because you'll burn up during reentry.
And so that's one of the things that we've
talked about, we've learned about, but nobody
has ever really thought about, or no one has
ever really come up with an easy solution.
If you had to do an EVA to close those doors,
how you'd ever do it, you'd have to do a spacewalk
back to the back here somehow.
And maybe hold on to the, there's just no
easy way to get underneath there to close
those.
But we talk about it, we come up with some
ideas, but
Never had to be done.
There's never had to be done and there was
never a procedure set to do it.
Thankfully these doors successfully closed
on every single space shuttle mission.
The external tank is now on its way back to
earth's atmosphere, helped along by a vent
opening in the oxygen tank that causes the
tank to tumble away from the orbiter.
With the thrust of the main engines gone the
astronauts have instantly become weightless,
a serene moment that filled Bruce with so
much joy that he forgot his first job as a
rookie astronaut.
Now, we always took a nice closeup picture
of the external tank right after Meco, because
if you'll remember, the external tank was
the only part of the space shuttle that wasn't
reused.
The boosters would fly back or splash down
in the ocean, we'd tow them back in, refurbish
'em, the shuttle would come back.
But the external tank, as soon as we got off
the tank, it would start tumbling back to
earth and break up and burn up, reentering
the atmosphere and just splash down little
pieces.
So we always wanted to take a nice big closeup
picture of the tank right after we got off
it to see if there was any abnormality with
it that might be generic that we'd need to
fix before the next shuttle took off.
So my very first job as a rookie was to, as
soon as we got to miko instantaneously, zero
G was to get unstrapped out of my seat, float
down to a locker by me, get the proper camera
out, float up to the overhead window while
Dick Richards the commander on my first flight,
was pitching discovery over on its back so
that we could take a picture of this tank
as it's following away back to earth.
Well, I floated up to the overhead window
and I'm looking outside and Dick says, Hey
Bruce, you should be seeing it.
And I said, yeah, Dick, I do.
It's awesome.
It's beautiful.
He said, well, why aren't you taking any pictures?
I said, pictures of what?
Oh, the tank.
I was so blown away by seeing Earth for the
first time from the space shuttle that I choked
on my first job and I was supposed to have
this great big picture of the tank.
Well, by the time I took a picture of the
tank, it was like falling away from us, but
it was just beautiful.
It was just seeing the earth for the first
time from space is probably my most memorable
experience.
This is just the first stage of the incredible
engineering of the Space Shuttle.
This was a reusable spacecraft designed to
provide the astronauts all the tools they
need to survive and work in orbit, including
sleeping quarters, life support, airlocks
and orbital maneuvering systems.
We will be continuing this engineering odyssey
in the next episode of Real Engineering.
Sharing the devices and engineering that went
into the second stage of the Space Shuttles
mission.
Orbit.
Filled with incredible stories from Bruce
on his mission to save a stranded satellite
and the engineering that made it possible.
Which is available on Nebula right now, which
will be followed by a third episode dedicated
to the final stage of its mission, re-entry.
If you don’t already have Nebula, for a
limited time we are offering lifetime memberships.
A one off, one time payment, to get lifelong
access to the largest creator owned streaming
service.
Or maybe you have Nebula already and would
prefer to switch over to lifetime to get away
from recurring subscription payments, while
helping us accelerate growth of our platform
without taking on venture capital money.
Or you could be a happy member already and
want to gift Nebula to someone special in
your life, and for that we also just launched
gifted lifetime subscriptions.
Whatever way you decide to sign up.
You will be rewarded with exclusive video
series like Wendover Productions Logistics
of series, detailing the logistics of arms
manufacturing, search and rescue, commercial
fishing and much more.
Or our own series about the Logistics of D-Day.
And early access to Real Engineering videos
without any ads, like episode 2 of the insane
engineering of the space shuttle, which you
can watch right now.
Normal yearly membership is 30 dollars a year,
or you get the discounted rate of just 2.50
a month with the link in the description.